there's a
an interesting open letter that was just
released
from uh several Folks at MIT Max tegmark
uh Elon Musk and a few others that is
asking
AI companies to put a six-month hold on
any further training of large language
models AI systems can you make the case
for that kind of halt and against it
so
the big thing that we should be saying
is what did we use a lot what what did
we do the last six months when we saw
that coming
and if we were completely inactive in
the last six months what makes us think
that we'll be a little better in the
next six months yeah so this whole six
month thing I think is a little silly
it's like no let's just get get busy do
what we were going to do anyway and we
should have done it six months ago sorry
we messed up let's work faster now
because if we basically say why don't
you get us pause for six months
and then you know we'll think about
doing something in six months we'll be
exactly the same spot
So my answer is tell us exactly what you
were going to do the next six months
that's why you didn't do it the last six
months and why the next six months will
be different and then let's just do that
conversely as you train these large
models with more parameters
the alignment becomes sometimes easier
that as the systems become more capable
they actually become less dangerous than
more dangerous
so in a way it might actually be
counterproductive to sort of fix
the March 2023 version and not get to
experience the possibly safer September
2023 version
that's actually a really interesting
thought there's several interesting
thoughts there but the idea is that this
is the birth of something that
is sufficiently powerful to do damage
and is
not too powerful to do
uh irreversible damage at the same time
it's sufficiently complex to be able for
us to enable to study it
so we can investigate all different ways
it goes wrong all the different ways we
can make it safer all the different
policies from a government perspective
that we want to in terms of Regulation
or not how we uh
perform for example the uh reinforcement
learning with human feedback in such a
way that gets it to not do as much hate
speech as it naturally wants to all that
kind of stuff and have a public
discourse and enable the very thing that
you're a huge proponent of which is
diversity so give time for other
companies to launch other models give
time
to Launch Open Source models and to
start the play where a lot of the
research Community brilliant folks such
as yourself start to play with it before
it runs away in in terms of the scale of
impact it has on society my
recommendation would be a little
different it would be let the Google and
the meta Facebook and all of the other
large models make them open make them
transparent make them accessible let
open AI continue to train larger and
larger models let them continue straight
large and larger models let let the
world experiment with the diversity of
AI systems rather than sort of fixing
now
and
you can't stop progress progress needs
to continue in my view
and what we need is more experimenting
more transparency more openness
rather than oh open AI is ahead of the
curve let's stop it right now until
everybody catches up I I think that's
um doesn't make complete sense to me the
other component is we should yes be
cautious with it and we should like not
give it the nuclear codes
um as we make more and more plugins yes
the system will be capable of more and
more things but
right now I think of it as just an
extremely able and capable assistant
that has these emerging behaviors which
are stunning
rather than something that will suddenly
escape the box and and shut down the
world
and the third component is that we
should be taking a little bit more
responsibility for how we use these
systems basically if I take the most
kind human being and I brainwash them I
can get them to do hate speech overnight
that doesn't mean we should stop any
kind of education of all humans we
should stop misusing the power that we
have over these influenceable models so
I think that the people who get it to do
hate speech
they should take responsibility for that
hate speech I think that giving a
powerful car to a bunch of people or
giving a truck or a garbage truck should
not basically say oh we should stop all
garbage trucks until we like because we
can run one and one of them into a crowd
no people have done that and there's
laws and there's like regulations
against
you know running trucks into the crowd
trucks are extremely dangerous we're not
going to stop all trucks until we make
sure that none of them runs into a crowd
no we just have laws in place and we
have mental health in place and we take
responsibility for our actions when we
use these otherwise very beneficial true
tools like garbage trucks for nefarious
uses so in the same way you can't expect
a car to never you know do any damage
when used especially like specifically
malicious ways and right now we're
basically saying oh well we should have
these super intelligent system that can
do anything but it can't do that I'm
like no it can do that but it's up to
the human to take responsibility for not
doing that and when you get it to like
spew malicious like hate speech stuff
you should be responsible
so there's a lot of tricky nuances here
that makes this different because it's
software so you can deploy it at scale
and it can have the same viral impact
that software can so you can create Bots
that are human-like and it can do a lot
of really interesting stuff so the raw
GPT 4 version you can ask
how do I tweet that I hate they have
this in the paper I remember that I hate
Jews in a way that's not going to get
taken down by Twitter you can literally
ask that or you can ask how do I make a
bomb for one dollar yeah and
if it it's able to generate that
knowledge yeah but at the same time you
can Google the same things it makes it
much more accessible so the scale
becomes interesting because if you can
do all this kind of stuff in a very
accessible way at scale where you can
tweet it
there is the network effects that we
have to start to think about it
fundamentally is the same thing but the
speed of the viral spread of the
information that's already available
might have a different level of effect I
think it's an evolution in your arms
race nature gets better at making mice
and juniors get better making mouse
traps and
um you know as as basically you ask it
hey can how can I evade Twitter
censorship well you know Twitter should
just update it censorship so that you
can catch that as well and so no matter
how fast the development happens the the
defense will just get faster yeah we
just have to be responsible as human
beings and kind to each other
yeah but there's a technical question
can we always
win the race and I suppose there's no
ever guarantee that we'll win the race
we will never like you know with my wife
we're basically saying hey are we ready
for kids
my answer was I was never ready to
become a professor and yet I became a
professor and I was never ready to be a
dad and then guess what the kid came and
like I became ready so ready or not here
I come but the reality is
we might one day wake up and there's a
challenge overnight that's extremely
difficult for example
we can wake up to the birth
of billions of bots that are human-like
on Twitter and we can't tell the
difference between human and machine
shut them down you don't know how to
shut them down
there's a fake manolis
on Twitter that seems to be as real as
the real men knows yeah how do we figure
out which one is real again this is a
problem where an afarious human can
impersonate me and you might have
trouble telling them apart just because
it's an AI it doesn't make it any
different of a problem but the scale you
can achieve this is the scary thing is
the speed and this the speed with which
you can achieve it but Twitter has
passwords and Twitter has usernames and
if it's not your username the fake Lex
Friedman is not going to have a billion
followers Etc
uh uh
uh I mean this all of this becomes so
both the hacking of people's accounts
first of all like phishing becomes much
easier that's already a problem it's not
like AI will not change that no no no no
AI makes it much more effective
currently the emails the phishing scams
are pretty dumb like to click on it
you have to be not paying attention but
they're you know with with language
models they can be really damn
convincing so what you're saying is that
we never had humans smart enough to make
a great scam and we now have an AI
That's smarter than most humans or all
of the humans well this is the big
difference is there seems to be human
level linguistic capabilities yeah that
in fact superhuman level superhuman
level it's like saying I'm not gonna
allow I'm not gonna allow machines to
compute multiplications of 100 digit
numbers because humans can't do it like
no just do it don't miss it no but we
can't disregard I mean that's a good
point but we can't disregard the power
of language in human society I mean yes
you're right but that seems like a scary
new reality we don't have answers for
yet I remember when Gary Kasparov was
basically saying you know great you know
chess beats you like chess machines beat
humans or chess yeah you know are you
like are are people going to still go to
chess tournaments and his answer was you
know well we have cars that go much
faster than humans and yet we still go
to the Olympics to watch humans run so
that's for entertainment but what about
for the spread of information and news
right uh what that has to do with the
pandemic or the political election or
anything it it's a scary reality where
there's a lot of convincing Bots that
are human-like telling us I think that
if we want to regulate something it
shouldn't be the training of these
models it should be the utilization of
these models for XYZ activity so
yeah like yes guidelines and guards
should be there but against specific set
of utilizations sure I think simply
saying we're not going to make any more
trucks is not the way
that's what people are a little bit
scared about the idea they're very torn
on the open sourcing yeah the very
people that kind of are proponents of
open sourcing have also spoken out in
this case we want to keep a closed
Source because
there's going to be you know putting
large language models pre-trained
fine-tuned through uh RL with human
feedback putting in the hands of I don't
know terrorist organizations of
a kid in a garage who just wants to have
a bit of fun through trolling
it's a scary world because again scale
can be achieved and we the the bottom
line is I think why they're asking six
months or sometime is we don't really
know how powerful these things are it's
been just a few days and they seem to be
really damn good I am so ready to be
replaced seriously I'm so ready like you
have no idea how excited in a positive
way I mean in a positive way where
basically all of the mundane aspects of
my job and maybe even my full job if if
it turns out that an AI is better I find
it very discriminative basically say you
can only hire humans because they're
inferior I mean that's ridiculous
that's discrimination if an AI is better
than me at training students
get me out of the picture just let the
AI train the students I mean please
because like what do I want do I want
jobs for humans or do I want better
outcome for Humanity yeah so the basic
thing is then you start to ask what do I
want for Humanity and what do I want as
an individual and as an individual
you want some basic survival and on top
of that you want Rich fulfilling
experiences that's exactly right that's
exactly right and as an individual I
gain a tremendous amount from teaching
at MIT this is like an extremely
fulfilling job I often joke about if I
if I were a billionaire in the stock
market I would pay MIT an exorbitant
amount of money to let me work day in
day out all night with the smartest
people in the world and that's what I
already have so that that's a very
fulfilling experience for me but why
would I deprive those students from a
better advisor if they can have one
take him